[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back to
"Eyes on Enterprise,"
where I bring in Googlers
to talk about the technology
landscapes that are shaping
how enterprises adapt,
modernize, and scale.
I'm Stephanie Wong,
and today, I'm
bringing back on Brian Dorsey.
He is a developer
advocate for Compute,
and we're going to be talking
about how you should rethink
your VMs, which I'm
excited to hear about,
because I'm unsure of what
you actually mean by that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Excellent.
Let's do it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's start
by examining our assumptions
about VMs.
What are some of
those assumptions?
To me, a VM is a
virtual computer.
You have CPU, memory,
disks, networking.
What else is different here?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yes,
that's exactly it.
It's relevant, though,
that it's the base of many,
many of our other services.
It is super common
in architectures.
Everybody's running some VMs.
But if you're only thinking
about it as a classic VM,
you might be leaving time
and money on the table.
STEPHANIE WONG: Oh.
Time and money.
That's everyone's
top-of-mind, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yep.
STEPHANIE WONG: Interested
in hearing more,
but as I imagine, don't
Google Cloud VMs typically fit
in that model?
BRIAN DORSEY: At
a high level, yes.
It is an abstraction of
this CPU network disk RAM.
But we're used to
thinking of that
as a slice of one
computer, and it's really
a slice of resources that are
across the whole data center.
That enables a whole bunch
of agility and reliability
that you wouldn't notice
otherwise or you might not get.
STEPHANIE WONG: I imagine
this is the basis of what
you mean by rethinking VMs--
slice of a data center.
Can you dive into
more about how that's
truly different than otherwise?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
An example of that is,
when you buy a computer,
it's a big decision.
You buy it, and you have
it three to five years,
or whatever, and you're
stuck with that shape.
When you turn on
a VM in the cloud,
you're really setting the
configuration for that machine
right then.
And if you turn it off, you can
keep the disk around, the boot
disk, and then you can just turn
it back on with a completely
different configuration.
So you can be like, oh,
I've got a two-core machine.
Or, now I've got a 25-core
machine or a 250-core machine,
and maybe I only want
that for an hour or a day.
That kind of thinking gives
you a bunch of flexibility
to be able to respond
to peak loads,
to do reports that
need a big crunch
at the end of the month--
whatever it is, without
building a lot more complexity
into the system.
STEPHANIE WONG: Google
is a huge company,
and we have a large amount
of Compute power in the data
center.
What's possible with this
amount of infrastructure?
BRIAN DORSEY: I think
the classic thing
that people talk about
is scaling out, right?
You've got one service.
Then you run it on
multiple machines,
and you can scale
out really well.
That's true.
But also, I think things have
snuck up on us a little bit.
The level that you can
scale up to has gotten huge.
Our largest VMs are,
currently, 416-core machines
with 12 terabytes of
memory, large disks,
and that sort of thing.
So the limit that you can
scale a given machine up to,
like a database, is
quite high, and if you
do keep it to one machine,
you simplify things a bit.
I was shopping for
hard disks recently,
and the largest one I could
find was 14 terabytes.
You can get a machine with
almost that much memory
as you'd normally buy for
disks, so there's plenty of room
to scale up as well.
And for apps that have
been around for a while,
scaling out could mean
a whole re-architecture.
Or scaling up, you
could just turn a dial,
and it can really help
solve a lot of problems
and save time and money.
STEPHANIE WONG: Why
does scale-up actually
matter in this case?
BRIAN DORSEY: Some of
the concrete examples
are, like, a database, which
can get really complex when you
start trying to [? short ?] it.
Another common use case
for the really big machines
is things like SAP HANA which
is a large in-memory database.
It just has to run
on one machine.
Things like that.
I think it just gives you more
headroom to keep things running
that you don't--
it's not the time to do
a big re-architecture
for the organization,
but it does need
to grow with your organization.
You can do that more easily.
STEPHANIE WONG: You
mentioned VM reboots.
How fast is that,
actually, on Google Cloud?
BRIAN DORSEY: It's
actually pretty quick.
We can start a machine
from scratch, boot the OS,
get to your code running
in 20 to 30 seconds.
For a lot of situations,
that is plenty fast.
And that's from nothing.
There's no planning, no
talking to another team
for provisioning.
It's just ready to go.
STEPHANIE WONG: I've
worked with VMs before,
and that usually involved
deploying the hypervisor
and deploying the VM on
VirtualBox or VMware,
for example--
a lot of steps, I concur.
So is it easier
here, in this case?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
I think the main
thing is not worrying
about management of all of
the machines underneath.
You actually don't have to worry
about the Tetris game of trying
to fit your VMs in with
the right other VMs,
or whether you have
space for them.
That sort of thing.
That still happens, but
it'll happen on the back end.
You don't have to
worry about it.
STEPHANIE WONG: What does
this all mean, practically?
BRIAN DORSEY: You can make
the machine that's exactly
the right shape
for your workload
and not leave idle
machines running,
because they cost money.
You can actually make
it the right shape.
The other place
this plays out is--
when you're running
all your own stuff,
you're always trying
to keep the most
utilization of the
hardware you can,
because you've paid for it.
You want to use it, right?
If you can make a
machine that is exactly
the right shape
for your workload,
you automatically get
the right utilization.
In fact, we'll even recommend--
oh, hey, this machine
isn't getting as much
use as it could be.
You might want to
make it smaller.
Or vice versa.
It seems to be slammed.
Maybe it needs to
be a little bigger.
That sort of thing.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
You're moving away from the
mental model of "How do I
make the most use of this
box that I've already
deployed, procured, and
paid for" versus, "OK.
I've deployed it,
but I can actually
backtrack and redeploy
using a different shape,
so I can optimize for the
CPU utilization, memory,
and all these other things."
BRIAN DORSEY: That's true
both with the planning--
you don't have to overcommit
early on in a project.
But I think, again, where
it's not so obvious,
is that time scales
can be short, too,
so you can reboot it and run
it for an hour in the bigger
shape, or a certain time of
the month, or what have you.
STEPHANIE WONG: We
talked about scale-up.
What about scale-out cases?
BRIAN DORSEY: This is like the
classic sweet spot for Cloud,
where you have multiple
computers cooperating
to do things.
We have tools built
in to Compute Engine
to help you scale up and down.
There's a thing called
managed instance groups that
connects to a load balancer, and
you can, either automatically
or on your config, decide how
many machines are actually
behind that load balancer.
It can be one, or it can be
20, and that can automatically
scale up or down
or be on a dial.
You basically call an
API for how big or small
you want it to be.
In addition to that,
there are cases
where you want to be
doing batch workloads
or where those
machines don't all
have to be running that
much, and it really
helps us out, for planning,
if we can schedule things.
So we offer a very
large discount
on machines that
don't live that long.
They're called preemptible VMs.
Basically, these VMs can
never live more than 24 hours
per machine, but they are an
80% discount in many cases,
so you can be looking at a fifth
of the costs of another thing.
If you've got a batch
workload, or if you've
got a system with very little
state on the particular worker
machines, you can save
a lot of money that way.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's talk
about access to the VMs.
Previously, I remember
having to SSH into VMs or RDP
into a Windows
machine, and then I'd
have to save my
session login info
and target the public
IP address of the VM.
There are multiple steps, and it
wasn't always straightforward.
Is this the same
with Google Cloud?
Are there easier ways
to access your VMs here?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah,
or maybe you create
a jump box that's behind
the firewall you VPN into,
or something like that, right?
If you need to, you can
still do all of those things.
It's very flexible.
And if you've got processes in
place, you can keep doing them.
But we also have
a couple of tools
to make things easier than that.
When you're using
the web console,
you're already logged-in and
authenticated with Google.
You've got a user.
We know who you are and that
you have access to that project.
There's actually a web-based
command line console.
You can just click
a button on any VM,
and it will send an
SSH key back and forth,
and you can log right in.
STEPHANIE WONG: Nice.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's super
handy for one-off situations,
emergency things, or on a tablet
when you're out, or whatever.
On the other hand,
there is a strong need
in large organizations to
keep careful track of who's
allowed to log in where
and automate that.
There's a system called OS
Login that basically delegates
the "who's allowed" part of
it into the overall permission
structure of Google Cloud,
which is called IAM.
You can basically
delegate that there.
Users can pick
their own SSH key,
but the central group
can decide who's
actually allowed to log in
to which boxes with that key.
STEPHANIE WONG: Is
this making it easier
for administrators,
who are always
trying to manage
public-private key pairings
and sharing it out
with their teams?
How does it make it
a little bit easier?
BRIAN DORSEY: You can just avoid
a bunch of potential mistakes
or grunt work of dealing
with all of those,
and I think, on top of that,
you can audit it better.
You can tell exactly what
the current configuration is,
or you can change it on the fly.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's
talk about disks.
When I think of disks, I
imagine you have a boot volume.
You have additional
volumes for more storage.
Is that how they work
on Google Cloud, too,
or different in this case?
BRIAN DORSEY: This is another
example of "yes, and more."
STEPHANIE WONG: "Yes and."
BRIAN DORSEY: "Yes and."
Your model's right.
You've got these disks that
you can attach or detach
between multiple machines.
But they are, again, a
slice of a data center.
The disks are
actually, by default,
network-attached
storage, but they're not
attached to some particular
machine out there.
They're attached to hundreds
or thousands of machines
to get the data back.
So you get very
consistent performance,
you get a lot of flexibility
to change things very quickly,
and it enables features like--
if your disk fills up, you
can just make it bigger.
It also enables things that
are really not obvious.
Normally, a disk is in a
particular physical location.
Since these are
already spread out,
we've got a mode
where we actually
spread the blocks across two
zones or across a whole region.
You can have what looks
like one disk to the VM
actually living in two
physical locations,
so you get a whole bunch
of disaster recovery crisis
mitigation without actually
changing the app at all.
Essentially, what you get
is the 80-20 of a SAN.
You get a lot of
the features you
want out of a SAN-based
disk, but in the cloud.
The other thing that I think is
maybe not so obvious is that--
we think of a computer
as this physical box,
but in our Cloud VMs, the
disk is really the identity.
A boot disk has the operating
system and all your software
and everything, and
the computer part
is what happens to be
configured currently.
When you turn it off,
that part all goes away.
And when you turn it back on,
we give you a new computer
off the same disk.
That changes the way you think
about reliability, resiliency,
flexibility, that sort of thing.
STEPHANIE WONG: You can
have persistent storage
for whatever operating system
and files that you already
have on that.
And then, if you decide
that you want to reboot,
and you want to reshape
your VM, for example,
then you still have
everything persisting there.
BRIAN DORSEY:
That's how it works,
so you know what we're
talking about earlier.
It's because that disk
lives on, past the config.
STEPHANIE WONG: This
all sounds great,
but are there any
gotchas or any caveats
here that we should be aware of?
BRIAN DORSEY: Of course.
There's always trade-offs
in the world of tech.
And I think one of the things
that's not super obvious
is that everybody wants to use
disks differently in the cloud.
Some people have
tons of storage.
Some people want
really high throughput.
And the way we balance
all of that out
is by actually connecting, like
on a real disk, the throughput
to the size of the disk.
It's not obvious.
We don't think about it that
way when we buy a real disk.
But there's a certain
amount of storage
and a certain amount
of I/O that you
get when you buy one of them.
We extend that out through
the whole platform,
so one of the things
that can be a gotcha is--
you go to do a performance test.
You pick a small disk, because
you're just doing a test,
and it doesn't work that well.
And you're like, what?
This thing sucks.
It's important to
look at the docs
and pick the right-size disk
for your throughput target.
The short version is that
larger disks are faster,
and they are a
network disk, so that
uses a certain amount
of the network, which
also uses some of the CPU.
The number of CPUs affects
the overall throughput,
and the size of the disk does.
So take a look at those
docs and make sure
that you size it right for the
workload you're trying to get.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let's
talk about a scenario
where you want to take
a snapshot of a VM
for disaster recovery or any
other use case related to that.
Is a different on Google Cloud?
Because I imagine you still
have to take a snapshot.
What can it enable
you to actually do?
BRIAN DORSEY: This is where
their being network-attached
storage is huge, because we can
take a snapshot without hardly
affecting the actual
usage of the disk at all,
and that snapshot can be used
to make a new disk anywhere
in the world, globally,
in the same system.
If you're just trying
to do straight backups,
or you want to make
another copy of it
somewhere else for reliability,
redundancy reasons,
that's really straightforward.
Additionally, if you're trying
to build a full-on disaster
recovery situation,
it might make sense
to think about the overall
system a little differently.
It may make sense to have
the database online and doing
a database-level replication,
maybe to a smaller instance,
and then the rest of the system
behind one of these autoscaling
groups, where it only gets
bigger, to full size, when
it's actually running.
This sort of thing is
something I've talked
to a couple of folks about.
They are thinking, oh, I
want to do disaster recovery
in the cloud.
We have 25 machines running
the full thing on our side
or in another zone.
We need 25 machines for
the disaster recovery site,
and it's the obvious,
straightforward way
to think about it, model it.
But likely, you
probably only need
one or two machines
running all the time,
and the rest of them--
you can take advantage
of the flexibility
and just make them exist when
you actually have a disaster.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
if that were to occur,
I'd imagine that there is a
pretty fast ability for it
to become active?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yep.
It's the same thing we were
talking about earlier, where
the individual machines
are up in 20, 30 seconds,
and they're behind the
same load balancer,
so they just scale up to
deal with the new traffic.
STEPHANIE WONG: We talked a
lot about a lot of things--
VMs.
We talked about load balancers,
disks, rethinking VMs entirely.
What can people do to get
value out of Cloud right now?
BRIAN DORSEY: That's,
in fact, the reason
I'm excited about
this, because VMs
are almost always the
next step for people
who are getting into Cloud.
It's closest to the
architectures they currently
have.
You can run almost
any software there.
So they're the next step.
And if you're building
up that architecture,
it really helps to dig a
little deeper on these,
because you can simplify or
maybe leave whole parts of it
out and still get the same
reliability or more, and more
flexibility out of it.
That's where the saving
time and money comes in.
I really encourage
people to go take a look
at the architectures
they're thinking about,
connect them to the features
we have to simplify them,
and see where you can
save some time and money.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Well, that's great
words to end on.
And also, I want to thank you
for coming back on the show,
because I think you have--
BRIAN DORSEY: Thank you.
STEPHANIE WONG: --so
much good insight
into shifting your
mental model of how
to think about Cloud and VMs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks again.
Everyone, again, please
join us next time
for "Eyes on Enterprise,"
and we'll see you again soon.